[موسيقى] على
الرغم من أنها كانت بداية صعبة للحياة في
الإدارة ، لم يكن لدى روني أي نقص في
الموجهين لاستخلاص المعرفة منه ، ولكن هناك
رجل واحد سيلجأ إليه روني في
أي وقت ،
أفضل نصيحة تلقيتها من أليكس فيرجسون
فقط للعمل بجد كل يوم و  هذا
هو أفضل ما يتحدث عنه دائمًا يعني
أفضل نصيحة
تلقيتها لأنه من
وجهة نظر كرة القدم من وجهة نظر المدرب
بالطبع ،
سترتكب أخطاء ، وستفهم الأمور بشكل
خاطئ
ولكن لا يوجد  عذرًا حقًا
لعدم عدم العمل ، لذلك كان هذا يمنعني دائمًا
ما الذي كان يحب اللعب
لأنه كان رائعًا ، لقد كان في الواقع
مستريحًا تمامًا ،
ليس هناك صدق وأنت تقرأ
كل القصص المختلفة في مثل بعد
خارج  لقد كان مسترخيًا حقًا
ويمكنك الركض
معه وقد يمازح معه ويتناول الأشياء ،
ولكن من الواضح أن يوم واحد من المباريات
يأتي عندما ترى أنه أصبح
جادًا ونعم نبيع
للاعبين عليك أن تطعمهم.
خلافات وأعتقد أن هذا أمر
جيد ، أشجع الآن مع
لاعبي فريقي على إجراء المناظرة والتحدث
لأنك عادة عندما تناقش الأشياء
تحصل على إجابة تصل إلى
استنتاج سواء
كان ذلك هو الصحيح أو الخطأ
الذي اعتدت عليه.  توصلوا إلى استنتاج بشأن
ذلك ، لكن لا ، كان من الرائع اللعب
لأنه هو السبب الذي جعلني أتعاقد مع مانشستر
يونايتد للعب معه ، لذا فقد
استمتعت حقًا بوقتي في
التساؤل وهذا هو السبب الذي جعل كريستيانو رونالدو
يقول إنه عاد إلى
ما تعتقده.  يجري هناك في
الوقت الحاضر
أعتقد أنه كان
كريستيانو أه
أنت تعرف أنه كان في ميسي ربما يكون
أفضل هدفين
ربما في تاريخ اللعبة
وأم ، فالأهداف التي حطموا الأرقام
القياسية لا تصدق
وأم ناتالي ستنزل عند  في
مرحلة ما ، وكما ترى على الأرجح إذا
لم يفعل الاثنان شيئًا ، فكل ما عليه فعله
هو الاستمرار في العمل الجاد
وانتظار هذه الفرصة ، وأنا
متأكد من أنه عندما يفعل ذلك ، فإنه يستحق ذلك
و  ه سوف تأخذه